[Music]
as a veterinarian it is very hard to
keep up with all the species I mean I
got the little grandma glasses I'm
reading that and it change every week
and it's enough to have one species and
thing change drugs change doing a quick
quick once over everything CH everything
changing so you always keeping up with
stuff so it's very hard and you think
about doing this for thousands of
species of of animals man what you got
there baby squirrel that was orphaned oh
wow leur oh wow hey bu how are you cuz
you never know what's going to come in
WoW hey
Pine okay perfect I'm just trying to
work
myself yeah so we still have each
other in I car in I
car I want to be down man like that
look come on
what's up baby look come on man we been
together too long hey that's it we all
today oh my goodness huh what comeing
the door you going to get one of us
that's how you going to get unless you
just really request the guy with the
ball hit or the one with the Mohawk
that's it oh you may ask what a handsome
guy and they know what to do up
front Buckley's here to get his knees
fixed Buckley a 4-year-old chaen is here
for knee surgery we made him fat wait
wait
she fed him treats all the time yes he
got treats and he my little sweet
baby hello hi what's up
baby anytime you have joint issues being
heavy is counterproductive and when
we're dealing with the weight thing
Buckley is is a dog that's been loved on
a lot Buckley issue is genetics it's
more common in the toy breeds in the
small breed dogs they have we call a
luxating patella which basically means
the kneecap flips out of joint and is
dislocated
we have to do surgery all right you big
good boy you big good boy all right come
on baby all
right Dr Ferguson is one of the best
orthopedic surgeons I've ever met all
right Buck you're doing good buddy you
ain't met a lot of people have you I me
a lot okay well good I really just want
to be sure that you met more people I
wasn't number one on the list of
one give him some happy juice get him on
n I'm happy juice all
right night night baby next thing you
remember we'll be up with brand new knes
how about
that as Dr Ferguson preps for surgery
Mario waits for Buckley to get sleepy go
night night boo
boo I'm ready for you
Mario if only I could go to sleep that
easy
although Buckley's surgery is routine
there are always concerns when going
under
anesthesia you always run a risk of
having issue with anesthesia no matter
what type of surgery you're doing we run
pre-anesthetic blood work to try to
lessen those unforeseen things that can
happen as long as we're prepared it
makes it a lot
better DR Horton hadn't had a whole lot
of Orthopedic experience so I'm showing
her what to do how to do this surgery we
going start with a cranial lateral
incision in
here now the kneecap is here normally it
would be there uhhuh okay and then it
it's been doing this the patella Groove
is too shallow allowing the KNE to
continuously pop out of alignment which
can be painful for Buckley and that's
why we're getting a discomfort so so
that's where our kneecap rides up and
down you see it's not it's not a big
Ridge there but we going we going to
open it up some give me some get some
flush right Mario we're going to
actually rasp or file down under here to
make this groove deeper with this kind
of speeds it up a little bit here as Dr
Ferguson works on Buckley's knee an
emergency comes in for Dr Hodes hey hey
summer hey give me some hand I got a
C-section up front Wy come
on can we get this
move man give me a glue glue
Luke Luke boss man we on Deck 1015 all
right Dei an American Bulldog is in
labor with one puppy stuck in the birth
canal when emeres come in everything
changes it's like a triage now I know Dr
hod needs the surgery room my thought
process is if something serious it's
probably going to take both of us so I
need to finish so we can have the room
as well as we can both double team this
thing and try to get it under control
I have to do this surgery quickly but I
have to do it
well I know I know I know I know
Bulldogs typically they they're born
with really large heads and a lot of
times you have to do cesarian sections
to make sure they come out safely in
this case the owner I went passing
thought maybe it could come out but the
head got stuck everything spiral down
here and at this point DD's life is in
Jeopardy and the puppy life is in
Jeopardy you going to go ahead and pull
it out or we just I'm trying it's stuck
CU I would like to get try to get this
one out his head is acent
stress I know swe all right all right
more
[Music]
loot come on baby oh yeah all right give
me give me some oxygen let me see clamp
give me give me something to tie this
this
[Music]
off suction drill my green suction
so how long you think it's been hanging
out about 2 3 hours 2 3
[Music]
hours no
heartbeat looking at the p and knowing
how long it's been there 3 hours I knew
there was no way this pupper probably
was
aive no heartbeat on that one I think
it's 3 hours kind of kind of long a long
time yeah thing out but all right we
going to make sure we save the rest of
them
though once I realized that this puppy
was deceased I knew it was time to move
on and and do what I was training to do
and get the rest of these babies out
alive shade let's get get her ready to
you would have emergency section
when you have bilateral patella luxation
surgeries when you but you know we can't
can't schedule
everything I need my C room ready to go
like NASCAR baby we're almost done
Buckley is looking
good Dr Ferguson wraps up Buckley's
surgery so Dr Hodes can get DD's
emergency csection started all right bro
talk to me when you get it ready we
ready all
right here you go bring it the Texs
quickly transfer DD in Buckley as the
docs prep for surgery how we looking how
we sounding I got your incubator ready
toes ready incubator ready people ready
all right we're going to exteriorize
this uterus
Dr Hodes will need to remove the puppies
quickly if they are to have any chance
of survival all right we going to take
out one horn let see if we can milk some
puppies want some sponges this first
baby going to be stretched make sure you
suction in go ahead and give me another
towel open up some more
towel it's still it's still two more in
this pack
do oh it's blue come on come on come on
come on need need somebody hey the next
one is blue all hands on deck I need
another hand I need somebody I need
somebody I don't my baby right here is
not
breathing go two of them in okay you
ready for another one all right we got
another stress baby he's out this one
out the sack I don't like that one no
sack there buddy come here poppy come
here I'm going to need another hand okay
typically we don't have clients follow
the patients back in their emergency
situation but you know at this point hey
it's all hands on Dick let's save these
I just need you just s stimulate them
see to increase blood flow M if a pupp
is born not breathing and it hasn't been
a very long time we usually can
resuscitate that puppet we can do CPR we
have aspirators to aspirate all the
fluid out the nose and the biggest thing
we want to get that puppy warm because
it has to be warm to go ahead and start
breathing in the old days used to say
slap a baby on the butt and to start
crying we don't quite slap them on the
butt but we're massaging and we're
basically stimulating getting all the
body functions back together
big right here yeah I need somebody to
get the baby let's roll let's roll
nobody crying this is stress all right
well this isn't stress some you going to
have to come get two anything going out
there my baby right here is not
breathing he's the very first one that
came out the very first one come on come
on come on come on come on come on there
we go that head is huge what's it eight
yeah anything going out there talk to
me
the worst thing a veter can hear is when
you ask your team what's going on in
their
silence I had heard any peeps out of my
eight puppies so my heart
dropped talk to me how we looking y it's
a it's a slow process trying to get a
little color come on come on come on
come on come on come on you A big one
come on come on come on come on he's not
breathing we're still
oh I got a breath I got a breath all
right I did come on I got a breath I
finally got a breath sound like good
news out
there they were stressed already and
then addition to we put mama need some
anesthesia so they got a live that too
that's why it's taking a little time to
come out all right come there we go I
got two breaths we got anything out
there I got three crime babies okay
Andre yes sir your magic number is eight
I want to hear eight we got you what
y'all got yeah she breathing she just
ain't squeaking yet but she is breathing
come
on
okay did y'all hear that squeaky T right
did y'all hear it yeah uhhuh I hear you
fuss it I hear somebody there oh I want
to hear eight oo D number how many
possible five uh oh Soo ain't the number
we moving up
though Sino won't do it we're going to
go ahead and put the three youngers in
incubator I think this daddy is ready to
put them kids in they just everywhere he
can't keep he can't keep control of the
kids that's the hardest task right now
keep them
together there she
go all right boss man I think you got it
from here all right bro
sir all right okay they're doing good
over here D okay this is the boys so the
two they a little slower they girls or
boys no they boys you know boys are a
little slower sometimes so come around
huh what yeah yeah they are okay yeah
talk to me come
on I I would say we got one that's slow
coming around all I want to hear is oo
he going to be name that's the name
going to be oo oo there we go perfect
name oo no doubt nice and pink
[Applause]
uh oh you hear that I heard it I heard
it well y'all look like proud Daddy's
over there like you're theivery room
y'all look like y'all Y look like y in
the delivery room that's
it this is beautiful beautiful look at
yeah especially when you got a little
like this how could you not be happy how
could you not be man you made me work
for it boy but I don't mind working if
you going to work with me so in the end
we were fortunate enough to save all the
puppies that were being held up by that
one puppy you know it was sad to lose
that one but we was quick to action and
we were able to save all the rest she
trying to take my pink let let let my
pinky go yeah but she they all they all
look real good here you go
mama you like that
face
I know you've been volunteering at the
clinic for the last few years we got a
chance to come in and see me do dog
surgeries and Cat surgeries and so this
going to be your first cow pal patient
Dr haj's son VJ is joining him today to
check some cows for pregnancy I remember
my first cow pal patient did it go
good I remember my
first today we headed out to my college
Alma model Fort Valley State University
and we're going to learn how to check
for pregnancy but we're going to see how
you do when you actually have to put
your hand into a female C I'm not scared
you ready for your first time I'm ready
for it I can do
it VJ is a very bright kid he is shown a
whole lot of interest in becoming a
vener I decided I'm going to show them
the ropes let's see if we got some
pregnant cows here okay dog come on here
you going to catch I'm going to catch
the cows in the shoes for you all
right
so what are we checking for we're
checking for pregnany check it for
pregnancy so we should be able to F it
at what day uh 40 day 40 after day 40
you should be able to feel it yes all
right mhm so you remember we reaching in
what we reaching foring for cervix we're
going to see if it's plastic and we're
going to go at it yes sir you ready yes
sir all right let's see what we
got it is almost impossible to
ultrasound or cows pregnancy early on
because with the rectal probe you really
can't get high enough or deep enough
because they're ruminant so you can't
get between the stomach and intestines
to figure out that there's actually a
pregnancy so the best way to go in is to
just reach your hand in with the rectal
probe you nervous yes why you nervous
sure just a little bit why you never
stuck your hand in the C
no hold on calm down you going as far as
you going to put the glove there you go
I've never done a a prject before and
I'm expecting some push back but it
should be a learning experience L up
come on ready M all right so we're going
in m so hold on hold on all right there
you go mid mid level grab it pull it up
go to the left listen when you grab this
you need to control this car all right
all right yeah this nice and easy nice
and
easy it's BJ's first time so as he
reaches in there's a whole lot going on
on the inside he could be reaching in
and actually be feeling the cervix he
could actually be feeling the ovaries on
the side or he could just be feeling
poop open up there you go huh keep going
uhhuh keep going you ain't in the cow
you should be able to feel the pill so
right over the edge it drops off almost
like ocean do you feel it feel it you
feel it drop off right so that's what
the Cal usually sits it you could if
it's big you could almost bounce the
head like a basketball I'm feeling cix
okay so that cervix kind of pull it see
if you can pull it a little bit
you got it mhm all right go ahead and
pull it out nice and eveny the same way
you came out nice and
easy nice and easy perfect perfect all
right now back up good job it wasn't bad
it was like a very weird sensation it's
kind of hard to describe it's just
warm yeah warm all around very weird so
do you think she's pregnant or
not yeah I felt something there you want
to bed on it how about your whole
allowance got dollar dollar a dollar
dollar let's see what we got all
right as I P this cow I don't feel a
fetus in this cow at all so I know she's
open and not pregnant so let's see if BJ
is caught on so we're on the farm she is
not pregnant so what you supposed to say
open louder louder
[Music]
open when when he found out that this
cow was not pregnant he had a yeah open
because everybody out here understands
that lingo and they know she's not
pregnant I take every opportunity I can
to teach him something you still want to
be a veterian yes really yeah you want
to walk around and stick your hand in
cows all day I'm not that bad
okay oh thank you I love
you good job being a father is probably
my number one job and I I couldn't ask
for a better kid I never wanted to tell
him what to do but when somebody's
watching you and want to be like you and
especially your kid want to emulate
you that's the ultimate
compliment all
right first time I pray check C was at
tusky yes sir and they lined them up
against the wall so I was like okay
here's go nothing and the first thing I
remember was it was very warm warm yes I
think for me it was the anticipation
leading up to the check because we
thinking man we going to but and this is
our third year we almost veterinarians
man we we we almost home so I was
excited so for VJ to do this at 14 I
think he's the only one in his school
can say that no I'm pretty sure I think
he had bragging rights no doubt about
it Dr Ferguson and Senior vettech Jordan
head out to a farm to see a potbelly pig
with an attitude problem hello Miss Lou
hey how are you how you doing today I
heard you got something for us to see
today M we'll we checking out
Zoe
Zoe we just got a call from a homeowner
who said that pig that she has has been
very aggressive and a problem they can't
control it and they want to know what
they can do to fix it Zoe
Emma why do we have all this around the
fence because she's been um getting out
she's been getting out
yeah we've been having an issue with our
Pig getting out of the pen and tearing
up our entire yard and we're really not
sure exactly what to do to fix that and
then you can spring your ankle if you
fall in one of the
holes hard to keep her in huh she like
to use that nose don't she yeah and our
whole yard looks like this when she gets
out oh so let's look this baby over let
me see if we can hear
something
okay hey we strong now when we want to
go somewhere we going to go I want to
put a ring in cousin you want to be
pretty don't you yes no I want to stop
roou you want to stop rooting yeah
rooting is natural pigs use their snout
to to burrow to find food for thermal
reasons cooling off there is no way to
stop them you will be stopping what
Mother Nature gave them how to be
resourceful we were just thinking that
if the ring was in her nose it would
irritate her so she wouldn't root so bad
was our thought probably not okay one
start to disrupt a pig's natural rooting
Behavior putting a ring in Zoe's snout
not only won't stop rooting but it's
likely to be painful we don't really
know how to stop them from rooting
because that's just what they do that's
their nature that's their nature
whatever area you put the pig in we just
have to allow the ne beer to do their
thing that's one of the things when you
got a pig it kind of comes along with it
just let her out every now and then you
don't have to leave her out okay you
know just get out and get a little
stretch making sure Zoe gets enough
exercise will keep her from being bored
and may reduce the amount of rooting she
does you ready to go run
go hell on
come on I I think I'm faster than a pig
there she goes oh my gosh where we going
oh my God might D at the
cuteness Zoe I think that was me so you
like animals yeah you want to be a
veterinarian yeah y'all can have a day
off and me and emo do it oh that's a
good idea sound like a winner when you
coming tomorrow be
good not
oh you have school
okay see you later future vetar spring
break I'm waiting on you so I can go
home okay we're going to North Carolina
oh I have to work then okay then I'm
going back to work all right there we go
lots of good information today rooting
it's a pig's nature ultimately we just
want Zoe to be
happy so who won the race Zoe won for
sure Zoe won maybe next
time
wle boo
[Music]
boo been one of those days good God
might y'all might have to call a human
fixer every day seems busy every busy in
the clinic I mean we'll have the day
planned we have X amount of surgeries in
the morning x amount of appointments
then you get a call to go out and see a
pig yeah or you get a call a C-section
is on the way or you get a call and it's
hit by a car and then I go hide in the
room where's a vaccine for a puppy then
you're looking for Dr hod anybody seen
Dr
hoders he's teasing he's always going to
be there
[Music]
all Dr HJ is welcomes buttermilk a
pregnant goat to the clinic hey hey
careful all right that's good we got a
sample so we all we don't even have to
get us a sample from Mom if we can take
this and I want you to set up a little
poopy
sample hello all right we're doing the
bounce test come on let's
go have you ever done that no come on R
you're going to put your hands here
literally here and here now Bounce It Up
you see how bounc this back do you feel
those little balls bouncing back M them
babies Andrea if you will get me some
rays on this baby all right let's see
what we got
right got follow the follow the Trail
Follow the trail one of my main things
as a veterinarian is to examine
poop all right I'm going set a pet up
and see if we got anything going on over
here while senior vet tech Andrea x-rays
buttermilk to check on the babies Dr
Hodes checks her feces for any signs of
parasites it's very important to make
sure that there aren't any parasites
because a parasite load can really
really affect a pregnant mother who's
giv all of her nutrition to these
growing
babies hey Doc yeah this is buttermilk
Mama all right so buttermilk doesn't
have any parasites but take a look at
this how many heads you
see right now only one oh keep looking
this is one head mhm look that head ah
five that's a head so two of this two
babies every everything looks good
butter mix pregnancy is completely safe
but it's going to require double care
from the owners I wish she'd hurry up
and have her it's real soon and you
going to be a grandpa probably in the
next few days it won't be long okay bye
buttermilk good job next time I see you
she had twins you have
twins you doing
good
[Music]
the weather actually turned out this is
a good alpaca baby hunting weather
that's right 4 Packers yall think 4
Packers pregnancy check if women were
pregnant for 11 and a half month that's
a long time 20 lb baby I've seen some
big babies but not 20 lb
babies Dr Hodes and Dr Ferguson are
heading to an alpaca Farm to see four
recently bred females and determin if
they are pregnant with babies called
Korea how's it going hey how are you
doing doing good how yall doing I am
Nancy with the franch and we have
alpacas that have been bred hopefully we
will have four koreas we have the
alpacas over here ready to go I'm going
to put the dogs up so they don't get
into what we're doing I look B
everything huh so who do we have here
this is Dawn hey Don and Dawn is eight
years old okay definitely take some
skill to Ultrasound alpaca and small
hands did you think you came because of
your alpaca expertise when you're on a
farm call it's never a dull moment so
we're actually going to do these
ultrasounds VI directum because you
can't really get your hand in the vagina
and because these are ruminants and they
have such a large abdomen you can't get
the RO to see these baby CRI here we go
girl all
right you see y see it pling this day
congratulations girl thanks that's right
so you're a good Mama I get a next we
got three
more it's okay baby that'll be much
better
for congratulations well that's awesome
we're two for two so far we're going to
make it three for three and four for
four all right baby it's okay there you
go good girl anything close she is I can
see it we're good good congratulations
all right all right so we ready for the
last one yeah what this baby name this
is Celeste hey sweetie so this would
also be her first first first Ultra
[Applause]
yes you can hey thanks so Ela may look
all cute and friendly but man don't let
that fool you right yeah it's okay no
ma'am it's
okay this is my clean hand they strong
they'll kick you they'll spit on you let
her go here come on yeah you okay oh I'm
fine okay so sometimes we out in the
field just have to improvise had to grab
a sock had to grab the Old Sock Man a
simple tube sock placed over the nose
and mouth stops the alpaca from spitting
at the Docks if you want if you want to
spit that guy over there give it to him
and that would be so good get my little
more Loop let's see if I can make
it it's okay baby it's okay yeah I think
we're getting
close there it is I can see it good job
all right congratulations all right know
you dog no doubt I want a half pack of
hug yeah oh four half Packers chick hey
four half Packers pregnant four for four
baby and I'm dry so we going to look be
looking for four babies next March March
April yep yes ma'am thank you I
appreciate it
[Music]
ma'am
Coco turn around baby coko a
seven-year-old boxer is here with a
painful eye condition Tuesday she woke
up with crying and her eye was all
swollen and she's never been sick this
is the first time she's ever been
injured anything so we had to bring her
in and We Came as soon as he opened the
doors all right let see what's going on
with this
baby all right we're going to go back in
the back we're going to do a quick stain
and we're going to see what we got going
on so initially on physical exam what
you want to do is something called a
florene stain and if there's a cut
abrasion or a corneal ulcer it will go
into that small cut so you turn the
lights off and the way you you check is
just a simple old fluorescent light all
right so we going if you can hold that M
thank you we going to stain this
eye ah so you see that crater in the
middle right there you see how it uptate
thing yeah we got a corneal
ulcer we're going to do what we call a
third eyelid flap we're going to bring
this little red thingy here across the
eye we're going to make us a nice little
tie and it's going to form a patch over
that eye since we don't have a blood
supply we're going to bring the blood to
the eye and we're going to make it just
like new sound like a plan M I can do it
on your eye too a
no hey I'm blinding one eye can't see
out the other give me a bre well that
give me a fif F shot no give me one
second all right girl oh come on you got
to work with me work with me go go work
she weigh 88 lb I know I just need to
get her
up oh do I didn't know you behind all
good come on big girl I wouldn't take my
dog anywhere else but here cuz Dr Hodes
he's such a great doctor and he
cares you put your own out there like
you J rown you put all out that
light thought you going bring CH BR
there boy let make the magic happen
baby third ey flp you got to be really
precise because you're going right under
the eye and right up under coming and if
you make a millimeter mistake you've he
the actual
[Music]
eyeball got actually two of them now I
can see little issues going on in the
bottom and we have just a little bit of
a problem so Coco came in today with
what we thought was one cornal uler on
the eye but look like there are multiple
cornal ERS here so as I'm pulling the
third eye lit up I have to make sure I
get it really tight and snug so that it
covers all the osers and hopefully he'll
die you pull out third eyelid up we're
going to go through using the third
eyelid to bring blood to the eye and
speed healing it's called conjunctival
flap therapy and we're going to create
our
flap there we go perfect so we bringing
a blood supply to that eye the I don't
have a blood supply but we going to make
sure that there is one there make our
cut all right puppy dog we got a third
out little flap we got a cornea that is
not protected in a week hopefully we'll
go ahead and get that thing healed and
we'll be good to go let's goe and wake
up baby y so I'm really pleased with how
this surgery turned out we were able to
cover up all the cornea oers and I think
this is going to be a real good outcome
all right good as
new say hey cone of shame cone of shame
and the main reason is I don't want to P
that eye and I'm going to take this off
in the week about 5 to seven days and
we'll take a look but I feel very
comfortable that we're going to get a
nice seal and we'll be fine that's good
that's good she's my baby I know and I'm
make sure no worries I thought it would
have lasted a lot longer than it did but
he was in and out I wish all surgeries
would like that time would you got to
keep this guy straight I know no way I
worry about her more than I do him so
thank see you later
dear best there's still going to be a
little bit more home treatment but
Coco's on the way to a healthy healing
eye there we go she ready to go I always
say that we had the advantage of of
Physicians because we get to treat
the dog or the patient and we get to
treat the client for sure so we have two
smiley faces going at the door as
opposed to just one that's the beauty of
our job it
[Music]
is we brought Cooper in cuz his ear was
swollen and today he's very low energy
cuz he doesn't feel good I think
naturally freak out a little bit
whenever you see something wrong with
your dog so you know we got a little
worried we knew we just had to bring him
in as soon as we could hey what we got
going on with this baby today swollen
left here swollen left there what's up
up
do you didn't say swollen Tong let's
just take a peek
here
ah we got a AO
hematoma a a hematoma is when there's
blood encapsulated between the two folds
of the skin often time it's caused by a
dog flapping his head
and the vessels break and that blood
just fills up and fills up and fills up
if left untreated it becomes hot and
inflamed and very painful and
uncomfortable for this dog and we can
have a lot of disfiguration in this air
without surgery Cooper's ARL hematoma
could cause permanent damage to his ear
flap what I'll do is I'll make a an
incision here we'll kind of fillet that
thing open I'll put it back together and
I'll put stitches in and we'll have a
good flat a like that right I'll take
this baby with me guys and we will will
get that fix thank you you're very
welcome come on with
me these are usually surgical cases
because a tissue called fibin starts to
form fibin is normally a good thing it's
a connective tissue that helps us heal
but on inside of the ear whether you
want the layer of the ear to stay closed
and the Hees it won't allow the ear to
heal you ready go night
night you are getting
sleepy you are getting sleepy
all right I'm going to get ready for the
show careful with the Mohawk boss
careful with the
Mohawk here we
go this thing is actually going to
almost
explode so make my
incision and as you can see the nice
ooze comes out get as much as we can
one thing about it when it's been going
on for a while this someone's fiberous
tissue see this
stuff is what I worry about depending
how thick the layer of fibrous tissue is
we may have some trouble getting it out
safely because the ear is very very thin
and you have to be really really careful
or you can actually cut through the ear
that's a lot of fire in this ear and
it's taking a whole lot of time to
scrape away this don't look
good kooper a hematoma has accumulated
so much blood in his ear It produced a
thick layer of fiber on the carage layer
inside so we got to make sure we scrape
away all the fibers tissue before we can
get it to heal properly or we could have
a lot of disfiguration in this
a so let's scrape this a little bit
more all right the five is gone and I
have what's in a Country Boy terminology
it look like it could be
scarified I don't know if that's in
Webster but in H's dictionary scarfi is
a word all
right removing the firing allows two
surfaces form a scar on the inside and
in Hees together so once I close it
suure it down it's what I call scarified
and that ear heals perfectly back to
normal
I always tell them when you go home and
when we take the bandages off it may
look like this dog has been in a fight
with Mike Tyson but I can guarantee you
in a few weeks when the hair grow it and
the ear flattens down you'll never be
able to know what
happen look at that butus butus it is
beautimus hey dog you ought to get that
made into a shirt bamus right that's my
word bamus that's it let's wrap this
here so we've done surgery to correct
this aroh hematoma the animals is in
abandon and I feel like this area will
heal very well the owner just have to
take good care of it over the next 10 14
days I feel like we going to have a
fantastic outcome after spending time in
recovery coper is ready to go home come
on CP time for you to bust out this
joint I know you got this lamp shade on
you know this guy Co you know this guy a
he looked a little sad to have a cone on
his head he's never dealt with that
before but you know all in all he looked
good uh he didn't look to be too upset
as if he was hurting that was good to
see I was worried about him but good to
see him okay thank sir take care
appreciate all
[Music]
right oh it's warm out here sounds good
out here mhm 6 weeks ago Buckley had
bilateral patella luxation
surgery he my little sweet
baby ever since then Buckley postoper
been back in the bandages are off I need
you to bend down man we going to see who
Mo who mohawk look the best
man after a couple of weeks Buck has
been repairing orthopedically yeah just
walk start and take a look he's doing
great with his weight he looks
tremendous he's 9 and 1 12 lbs l so he
is losing the weight and he's getting
his energy back and he's he's acting
like Buckley and he's playing with his
favorite toy the empty Coke botle so now
and we know he's getting better J pee
Buckley on prognosis is is great he's
walking around good I'm confident that
Buckley's owner is going to take care of
[Music]
Buckley
after a visit from Dr Hodes and Dr
Ferguson confirmed four alpaca
pregnancies the franch awaited the new
Crea arrivals with anticipation if you
want to spit that guy over there give it
to him and that would be so good luckily
we had a sock because I thought you
going to have to take one of yours out
no we're going to use your sock but no I
ain't wearing no sock yeah i a
get Georgia that's Farm I remember you
used to be a country boy I still am you
got two cities no man that's why yeah
and boo you don't got City I remember
you a country boy no man sist you a city
boy probably got peners on
too yeah I got pins out
here that's how the city bed come out
that's how the city BS come out that's
right man the good news is that your
ultrasound technique uh must been pretty
good good job city
boy
since Dr Hodes was here we have uh had
one Kaa born that was coton Joe longest
legs of Korea that I've seen he hasn't
quite grown into his legs yet and we
have the GS that are still pregnant and
due any time so we've been very lucky
this year all of the alpacas are very
healthy and coming along really well uh
that makes for a very good year for us
the fewer vet calls we have the better
we like
it you will come on in they'll be riding
and come get him 10 days after Cooper's
Ro hematoma surgery he's back to have
his stitches
removed can't
[Music]
no Cooper's doing much better after a
couple weeks ago getting his ear fixed
hey but you got a pain on this thing oh
man no pain last week Cooper came in
with the ballooned ear we call it the AO
hematoma most likely caused by a inner
ear infection and scratching or flapping
of the head this is a very painful
condition and the surgery to fix this
was very bloody so I'm anxious to see
how this ear is healing hey bud a it
healed up nice I remember you couldn't
even touch this dog ear yeah dog doesn't
hurt we about to send the dog home with
the owner and we ready to
go yeah what you think it looks
beautiful it's beautiful hey the seen no
thank goodness he wagging his tail he
ready to go you good you like I don't
want that guy he said let's go home oh
yeah he is good to go sweet thank you
all right see you later bye
[Music]
byee recently the docs performed an
emergency csection on Dei this first
baby going to be stressed and delivered
eight baby bullies I finally got a
breath yay y now these puppies are
living their lives stress free de doing
great she really taking to the pups real
nice being that this is her first litter
I really feel like she's doing good
really taking care of the pups she's not
too rough with them or anything like
that day I bought him home from surgery
she started lactating real well and
she's been a real good mom but we love
all of our dogs and take real good care
of
them when you're doing a cesarian or you
watching a a baby being born you and you
think like wow you know you the first
person that this baby has seen you know
so so it's it's an amazing thing and 6
weeks later you see them first vaccine
then you see them at 9 weeks and now
they're 2 years old and and you never
forget cuz you always either you or the
staff going to be like man you man we
delivered those puppies and it just it
just kind of warms your heart because
you know that you you played a major
role in the survival of the pup but also
the mother but also the owner so you you
know you had a hand in three different
things so it's very
[Music]
rewarding so last time we saw buttermill
the goat she was very pregnant it's been
about a month and she's giving birth to
healthy
twins when we brought buttermilk home it
was about five or six days before we
came out and she had had her
babies come here baby butter milk had a
nice smooth delivery there were no
complications she loves her babies she
runs around and plays with them all the
time little boy he's a lot slower than
the little girl so the little girl take
off and run really fast and the little
boy is more curious about
people it's been a month later and
butter is trying to wean her babies off
of her milk so now they like to eat her
food so glad we went to Critter fixers
and saw Dr Hodes he did really good with
my
[Music]
goats